من هنا انسحب الروس قبل ثلاثه اسابيع لكن
قذائفهم ما تزال تمطر المدينه
الروس معهم الى متى سيستمر قتل الاطفال
حرب اججرت مشاعر الكره لدى الاوكرانيين ضد
روسيا الرئيس الاوكراني يريد قطيعه تامه
حتى على المستوى
القانون من المستحيل على المنظمات الدينيه
التابعه لمراكز النفوذ الروسيه القيام
بانشطه في اوكرانيا
قرب مدينه
الجنود يوميا منذ بدايه الحرب تقدر
اوكرانيا انها خسرت 13000 من جنودها اما
روسيا فتقدر قتلاها باقل من سته الاف
جنديه والتقديرات الامريكيه تشير الى ان
كل طرف خطير نحو 100,000 من جنوده
بتوازي تستمر الهجمات الروسيه بالصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره لقطع امدادات الطاقه
والمياه والتدفئه عن السكان لكن ليس من
السهل النيل من الروح المعنويه
للاوكرانيين
يعزفون على ضوء الشموع وفي الريف مستشفى
الولاده اشبه بثنه عسكريه لحما الامهات
ومولدهم في اليوم الاول للولاده لم استطيع
نزول الى القبول حملوني على كرسي متحرك
وفي سياق موازن تبادل الروس والاوكرانيون
50 اسيرا من كل جانب كما اظهر فيديو نشرته
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه